In this problem we’re going to build the part of
our javascript parser that handles javascript
expressions. This is pretty straightforward, just
like the last problem where we’re essentially
numerating all the rules that we’ve predefined
for our javascript language. So let’s go right
through the I, the E.
So here we have the supply code for the
problem and if we look closely, we see that
almost all the parse float are numerated to
exactly what they should be. We have Identifier,
numbers, strings, true and false, how to handle a
not keyword do the opposite and then for
expressions. We are also given an enumeration
of the precedence and the associativity for each
of these operations.
So really we have everything we need in the
problem description to do this problem. And as
you can see here, I’ve already filled in the
precedence ordering for the operations. And this
has simply taken almost exactly right from the
comment given in the problem where or is listed
at the lowest precedence and we go all the way
up to division, right here. I’ve also added not
just to make it work.
So let’s start filling in the rules. My first rule is
going to handle. If we add a matching left and
right parenthesis, the expression that is equal to
is simply the contents of the parenthesis, pretty
straightforward. And now I have four rules for
some of our literal values. We have a number,
we’re going to say number and then the contents
of that string, just simply say the word string,
we’ve matched true or false, we’re going to
return the specified tuples. If we see a notch,
then we simply have in our Pastry that we’re not
and then the contents that are being.
Afterwards, we have about a dozen or so binary
rules. Addition, subtraction, times, modulus
division etcetera, etcetera and to save some time
I could enumerate each function, but I want to
take a short cut. So here I’ve said if we match
any of these things, I’m calling it a binary
operation. For the first element is new left,
upper end of the binary operation. The next
entry in our tuple is going to be the operation
being used and the last one its going to be the
right upper hand of the binary operation.
And now I have the expressions for function
calls, not just decorations, which we had in the
last problem. A function call is going to be
identifier, with optional argument in between
parenthesis. And the code for handling optional
arguments is almost exactly the same as the
code we use to handle, optional arguments in
the function decoration. In fact, I think it is
exactly the same. And with all that, we’ve done
it. It’s about 50 lines a code and we are happy.